demain la NASA va tenter de faire
quelque chose d'exceptionnel elle va
essayer de dévier un astéroïde c'est la
première mission du genre la NASA veut
se préparer ainsi au pire des scénarios
celui ou un astéroïde se dirigerait vers
la terre aux commandes de la mission une
Québécoise Julie Belrose
[Musique]
c'est un dimanche matin comme les autres
dans ce marché local de Californie les
gens s'activent et parmi eux une
scientifique de la NASA personne ne la
connaît personne ne sait même ce qu'elle
prépare et pourtant Julie Belrose
s'entraîne à sauver la Terre
[Musique]
cette québécoise dirige une mission une
mission qui se produit à 11 millions de
kilomètres de la Terre son objectif est
crucial dévié un astéroïde
[Musique]
on ne lance un satellite qui va aller
frapper un astéroïde puis on veut savoir
à quel point on est capable de le
pousser de changer leur bête
le programme est peu connu mais la NASA
a un plan de défense planétaire l'idée
c'est de se préparer au pire des
scénarios
ça c'est vraiment la première mission
dans le cadre de défendre la planète des
asturés des comètes des petits coeurs
qui pourraient venir vers la terre on
l'oublie mais la terre est constamment
bombardée
l'extinction des dinosaures nous
rappelle les ravages que peut produire
une météorite lorsqu'elle frappe la
Terre notre bouclier de protection c'est
l'atmosphère mais cette enveloppe
gazeuse qui permet de désintégrer les
météorites n'est pas infaillible la
communauté scientifique est technique
ont poussé pour avoir cette mission là
pour pouvoir dire bon mais on a fait de
la recherche pour à savoir quelle
méthode qu'on peut utiliser pour se
défendre contre des cotes comme ça la
probabilité est très petite mais elle a
quand même
la NASA lance une mission digne
d'Hollywood
comme dans le film Armageddon ici la
réalité s'approche vraiment de la
fiction
[Musique]
sauf que il y a un point d'astérieux
dans ce moment qui vont frapper la Terre
c'est pas impossible mais en ce moment
c'est improbable donc vous n'êtes pas la
Bruce Willis de la NASA non
[Musique]
c'est peut-être mieux qu'on soit préparé
que pas préparé
un voyage de 9 mois avant d'atteindre sa
cible 9 mois durant lesquels sa destinée
se retrouve entre les mains de Julie
Bellerose moi je suis la chef de
navigation pour la mission dirt notre
travail c'est
d'évaluer la trajectoire du satellite
voici les membres de dirt
des scientifiques recrutés pour mener à
bien la mission ici pas de GPS ni de
cartes pour arriver à bon port l'outil
navigation c'est l'ordinateur
un travail en fait tous les jours c'est
beaucoup de calcul beaucoup de
programmation
leur cible c'est un petit astéroïde de
260 mètres appelée dimorphos
c'est comme si on lançait une voiturette
de golf contre la pyramide de Khéops
si les ont choisi dimorphoses ce qui
n'est pas seul il orbite autour d'un
autre astéroïde cinq fois plus gros
en frappant le petit astérieux c'est ce
qu'on vit c'est plus petit c'est plus
facile à bouger et après c'est plus
facile de mesurer le changement
toutes les missions spatiales se
déroulent ici dans cette salle de
contrôle
malgré la technologie mise à la
disposition du lit Belrose l'incertitude
fait partie de son quotidien
le cerveau roule toujours et surtout
quand on arrive vers la fin dans les
événements comme critique comme ça
étonnamment la position de la sonde et
celle de l'astéroïde reste imprécise de
quoi affecter les chances de succès
plus 50% que 90%
imaginez Julie Belrose doit viser une
cible qui bouge constamment
[Musique]
l'incertitude autour de la position de
l'astéroïde est un prêt de 25 km nous
notre travail c'est de faire une
manoeuvre qui va nous amener à
l'intérieur de deux kilomètres
[Musique]
en 9 mois on a corrigé 6 fois la
trajectoire de la sonde pour obtenir
cette précision c'est l'activation de
ces propulseurs qui a permis d'ajuster
l'alimentation si tout va bien ça doit
être 99% de chances d'impact
[Musique]
il y a quelques jours un anneau
satellite s'est détaché de la sonde
c'est un peu le cameraman de la mission
celui qui filmera l'impact
sur terre c'est la fébrilité le moral
est troupe est excellent
4 heures avant la collision Julie
bellrose et son équipe ne pourront plus
rien faire ils devront lâcher prise
parce que jusqu'à ce moment-là on voit
pas la stéroïde qu'on va frapper encore
on voit juste le plus gros astéroïde
quand il sortira son ombre il sera trop
tard pour effectuer une manœuvre de
correction c'est à ce moment-là que le
système de guidage automatique de la
sonde prendra la relève
le plus grand défi de dirt c'est
l'impact et de faire en sorte que toutes
les systèmes fonctionnent de la façon
dont on pense
[Musique]
lundi 26 septembre c'est le jour J à
19h14 minutes et 23 secondes heure de
l'Est la sonde va s'écraser sur
l'astéroïde
même si l'impact est un succès c'est
seulement vers la mi-octobre qu'on sera
si l'astéroïde a été déviée
je me trouve chanceuse de pouvoir faire
ce travail là c'est extraordinaire c'est
sûr
ce matin la protection de l'humanité
prend une petite pause
Julie Belrose prend son café et caresse
nos va sa chienne blessée même quand la
survie de l'humanité repose sur vos
épaules certaines priorités ne peuvent
attendre
[Musique]